what would you say is the number one
reason that someone will not get a
distribution deal for their film the
number one reason that people won't get
a good distribution deal for their film
is probably because their film sucks
sorry you know it's like you know just
because you make a film doesn't mean you
know hey that it's good or be that
there's an audience for it now granted
someone could make a film that's not
that good but there's still an audience
for it and you know and again you say
distribution deal you know I think
generally why people wouldn't get a
distribution deals because their film
isn't good and or the distributor's
don't think there's a market for it that
they buy by purchasing the film they
won't be able to sell it to someone to
return their investment investment or
the war even if they don't purchase it
whatever money or work they put in won't
be profitable so and I think there's
plenty of distributors who buy films
that probably aren't that good but are
profitable you know and there's plenty
of distributors to buy films that are
neither good nor profitable but you know
I think the real question is you know
not to think about like why distributors
would buy or not buy a film but to think
about you know why what is your
motivation for making the film you know
how you can make that film as good as it
can be and how can you connect with an
audience around that film and to me
those are the same issues whether you do
it yourself or you know or with a team
do a direct to fan or with a distributor
I think those are the things that you
need to consider you know and those are
the things that distributors consider as
well you know and it could be the
greatest film in the world but if a
distributor still doesn't think there's
an audience for it you know they're not
going to pick it up and that happens all
the time where there's amazing films
that don't get released by traditional
distribution mechanism
and that's why I think it's really
important for filmmakers in all or just
to think about how they're going to
connect with their audiences you know
not be on reliant on someone else
you